[Music]
at more than $3 a milliliter it would be
cheaper to print your vacation pits with
Dom Perignon but inkjet cartridges are
95% water so what's the other 5% the
color comes from three dyes reactive red
23 direct blue 199 and acid yellow 23
each lives in its own cartridge with a
little ethylene glycol
that's antifreeze to keep it mixed with
the water each cartridge has hundreds of
tiny nozzles that spray drops of ink
thousands of times per second what could
possibly go wrong a lot for one thing
the adhesive strips you pull off when
you open a fresh cartridge a great at
keeping the ink from drying out but
they're also full of metal contaminants
left on the printhead for too long
the contaminants can foul the ink and
clog up the nozzles
that's where EDTA steps in its claw-like
molecular structure snatches metal ions
before they cause a jam then there's the
surface tension of the ink too little
tension and it will pour out of the
cartridge too much and a won't move at
all if tox elated acetylenic dials lower
it to just the right point but it's not
over once the ink hits the paper a
solvent called cyclohexadiene helps the
ink stick to the slippery polymers on
super gloss photo stock butyl urea slows
down the shrinkage that happens when
moisture evaporates from cellulose
fibres which would otherwise cause the
paper to warp and wrinkle that's a lot
packed into every drop but worth its
weight in fancy French Champagne you
make the call feeling wired yet
subscribe